ici le commandant x je ne suis pas un
héros de roman
j'existe il peut vous arriver de me
croiser dans la rue j'ai un nom de
famille je vous le cacherai comme je
vous cacherais mon visage et
circonstances l'exigent je suis encore
en service
je vais donc emprunter le visage d'un
comédien visage de michel doré pour vous
raconter une histoire que j'ai vécu une
affaire de renseignement comme on dit
dans le jargon de notre métier nous
sommes à casablanca en 1942 les alliés
viennent de débarquer en afrique du nord
de nombreux français ont franchi la
méditerranée pour venir se joindre aux
forces françaises libres mais par mieux
des suspects les agents envoyés par les
allemands pour espionner ou démoralisés
comment les reconnaître
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
on
mon commandant vous avez le colling le
sous-lieutenant morel à connantre avec
l'un de mes collègues cacherout merci
vous en pensez de quoi gâcher c'est un
cachou je vois même pas des amateurs de
catch ou moi j'ai un faible pour les
cachots ceux ci viennent de londres tous
les bons catch où sont fabriqués à
londres mais je ne vous ai pas fait
venir ici pour vous parler qu'échoue
avez-vous à me dire de cette affaire
pour même encore maintenant c'est une
affaire un peu particulière mais
demandez interrogé suspecte mais vous
avez à 1000 mhz à dire ce qu'on dû
raccrocher au juste on est seulement à
voir votre impression
elle est bonne elle est très bonne c'est
agathe heures français a franchi la
frontière espagnole de sa vie j'ai la
conviction que c'est par patriotisme
qu'il est venu se battre ici en france
dans les forces libres domicile oui le
cupide son prix modeste et nous n'avons
rien trouvé
ces dépenses normales
eh bien je vais vous dire maintenant
monsieur commissaire et charges qui
pèsent contre cet individu ne voudrais
pas passer mon dossier qu'elle contient
des renseignements ultra confidentiel
est l'un des dossiers cela traîne
toujours dans l'eau services et brûlent
connaître les services on use de
coffreur rester secrète et on livre ses
tripes se créa la femme de ménage pour
quel époux secte j'aurais bien d'autres
histoires à paris exactement à l'hôtel
lutetia un officiellement le major
snacker et savent tous chargés de
recruter des agents et durieux envoyé
ici en afrique du nord histoire de nous
intoxiquer
il a fait pas mal du tout sûr boulot de
ce n'est qu'hier
malheureusement pour lui n'est
heureusement pour nous il a des dossiers
et comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure le dossier c'est fait pour trait
les cte mes yeux indiscrets les
indiscrets non c'est moi qui les ai
placé à l'hôtel lutetia
jeux classiques les petits tours qu'on
ce jour entre services secrets mais
c'est mon homme ma bonne femme qui a
trouvé le nom de morel dans les papiers
de ce n'est guère prévenu je suis
aussitôt une enquête et j'ai appris
qu'en avril 1943 d'un morel en effet un
franchi la frontière espagnole
après un séjour de deux mois à barcelone
elle est arrivée en afrique du nord
une somme aurel le sous-lieutenant que
vous allez interroger nouveau cette
affaire je ne suis pas les flambard
n'ont pas vraiment chose contre il en
convient vous permettez nous avons
interrogé à mon tour dans votre présence
bien mon commandant alors je le fais
sans frais 1 et 6
ce que je pourrais savoir au moins où je
suis aura-t-on la décence élémentaire de
me dire où j'ai trop mal mais vous non
me calmer les envies de bonnes vous
arrête comme un malfaiteur c'est tout
juste si vous passez pas les menottes et
après on vous demande d'être calme vous
savez si j'ai risqué ma vie corner
jusqu'ici ce n'est pas pour qu'on me
traite comme un criminel
personne ne vous a traité en criminel on
a simplement voulu éclairer un point
douteux
d'abord qu'il un officier comme vos
lieutenants donc la camarade
comment dois je vous appelez ou cenon
commandant mon capitaine donc une
importance mon dieu nous allons garder
tenez asseyez-vous m'excuse ce n'est pas
très confortable
et puis fin de ces froids que
voulez-vous casablanca n'a pas prévu la
pluie n'a pas prévu non plus nos
services et nous avons dû nous contenter
de cette bâtisse pour fatma parfaite
pour abriter 1 à rennes mais détestable
regrouper nos bureaux bon ouais me
raconter dans nos petites histoires
comment êtes vous arrivée en afrique du
nord avant la guerre et vous vous
plaignez quand voudrait-on criminelle
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait un criminel
mais bon on lui demande son état civil
mais j'avais simplement omis de petite
formalité voyez bien on est entre
amateurs
viens je m'appelle jean maurel je suis
né le 10 décembre 1913 mes parents
tenaient un petit commerce à besançon
j'aurais voulu être ingénieur mais la
guerre est survenue
je me suis engagé dans l'aviation j'ai
fait le peloton au moment de la débâcle
j'étais sergent dans l'aviation
après d'un prêt après il a bien fallu
vivre
les explications sont très intéressantes
mais faisant un petit défaut n'explique
rien il vous manque 300 tickets devant
gary écouter entre france amélie tétouan
et on s'étonne qu'il est gay je te
répète amélie tu es toi c'est pas aux
femmes de cause et meftah qui alors
puisque les sommes sont trop larges
mais regardez moi j'en fus surpris main
je suis assez bien sa remontée ou pas
vous n'empêcherez pas de dire vous
faites a fichu métier dégoûté amelia de
même raison pourquoi ne cherchez-vous
des embêtements à notre âge prieto a
travaillé non madame je ne peux pas
travailler
oui moi je déteste mon métier autant que
vous tu pas un flic moi je ne suis pas
né pour être un flic suis militaire de
carrière dont va vous fâchez pas on n'a
pas voulu vous blesser combien vous
m'avez blessé quand même
croyez moi j'aimerais bien volé sur un
avion à lâcher des pruneaux sur les
[ __ ] que de trier vos salles ticket
comment vous étiez dans l'aviation et
pilotes
enfin presque
à la base de chartres je t'aime mess des
officiers alors comme ça j'étais
constamment un rapport avec ces
messieurs alors vous pensez
je connais tous vos problèmes non merci
si si c'est pas le fonctionnaire ont
cherché à acheter c'est le camarade de
guerre qu'on reçoit à venir va charger
l'anisette un labo guerre à cinq ans
radiateur oui alors messi sont
démobilisés je me suis retrouvé sur le
sable et parler tellement ressembler
c'est un sourd j'avais fait une mauvaise
affaire
pas d'argent pas de parents pas de
diplôme
j'aurais pu l'an passé mais la guerre ne
m'en avait pas laissé le temps
j'ai tenu le coup de trois mois puis un
jour un ami est venu me trouver j'étais
quelque chose dans le gouvernement
il a insisté pour que j'entre dans le
ravitaillement il m'a dit qu'il fallait
des gens honnêtes et intelligent et
finit par accepter
et vous avez eu raison parce qu'au fond
voyez-vous les honnêtes et les
intelligences et passent et moins
dangereux que les autres
secure - on peut se comprendre ouais je
cherche toujours à comprendre c'est là
son vrai père si je m'attendais pas à ça
fait plaisir
inquiet chez soi avec un aviateur
devrait aller encore de l'avant guerre
sans fait décente et pas maintenant on
est des amis nous méditons je pense à
quelque chose vous rendez des services
en ravitaillement c'est entendu mais
tout de même on préféreriez volet avoue
penser - volet c'était ma vocation
bon ben je vais tout peut-être pouvoir
vous rendre ainsi chris harris oui il ya
quelques jours un officier de nous voir
à mes dossiers
il se rendait à paris pour voler avec
l'autorisation des almohades nom très
peu pour moi je ne mange pas de ce
pain-là
qu'est ce que vous imaginez je suis prêt
[ __ ] moi non plus j'aime pas les
poches et aucun prix je les aiderai à
gagner leurs guerres nous donnons mono
fichier ne travaillait pas pour eux
vous allez tout de même pas me dire que
les allemands permettent de voler à des
gens qu'ils ne servent pas si pour des
vols commerciaux des vols uniquement
destinés au ravitaillement de la france
et des français
ça vous n'allez pas me dire que c'est
mal non parce qu'alors moi je vous
répondrai que c'est patriotique
je vous félicite monsieur d'être en bon
français un bon français doit servir son
pays et vous allez le service en
pilotant nous avions quand est-ce que je
commence incessamment le temps de
transmettre ce dossier et vous signerez
un engagement vous savez je suis pressé
moi j'ai tout liquider la zone libre je
ne connais personne en zone occupée
j'ai bien quelques économies mais la vie
est chère elles sont vite épuisé 1
les temps sont difficiles pour les
pauvres français et je ferai tout pour
que le dossier a vite très vite monsieur
mourad incessamment je vous le promets
incessamment nos services ont dû retenez
votre dossier
mais ce n'est qu'un accident j'espère ce
que savait choix fond de cale à moi je
fais plus qu'un repas par jour comme
c'est regrettable
je plains ces pauvres français qui sont
engagés imprudemment dans une guerre
barbare qu'il ne pouvait pas griller you
[Musique]
allez
tous des fumiers ces allemands elles
sont et marie sont gentils mais c'est
pour mieux nous rouler ce qui est moins
cher
je viens d'une libre j'ai tout plaqué
mois ses 55 ans et après mois les ponts
en bois l'asile de nuit bien ça me
regarde pas je m'en fous commander ou
servirait un rouge
c'est pas interdit non non c'est un jour
avec elle
monsieur vous avez eu tort de mal parler
des allemands j'étais en colère
les trois mois que leur service me font
poireauter les allemands vous le savez
ont beaucoup de soucis mener une guerre
contre le judéo capitalisme n'est pas
une petite affaire
croyez moi et sans doute
enfin je n'imaginais moi qui s'était
précis sont pas gueule c'est pas
pensable promettent ils promettent et
vous êtes sans doute tombé sur un
mauvais service dans toutes les armées
il ya de mauvais service des sans doute
raison mais je vous dois pas tant de 50
merci au revoir monsieur au revoir
heures
j'ai inscrits comment
[Musique]
et bien dites donc vous avez des relais
mais le foie gras ordonnée - il est de
gens n'avaient pas mangé maître d'hôtel
[Musique]
je vous avais demandé un pommard 1935 le
bien mon capitaine jeaunaux de survie
non ce pommard n'a pas le fruité du
pommard 1935
si je m'abuse pommard doit être un
pommard 1938 l'année de la pluie 1938
vous avez raison j'ai dû me tromper je
vous présente mes excuses mon corps dit
et ce alors ça pourra également vous est
rudement calais à munich et où j'habite
en temps de paix je possède je mens flac
une des meilleures cartes de l'allemagne
j'ai toujours apprécié les bonnes choses
venues de france
moi je vous n'appréciez pas autant les
français qui vous dit que je ne les
apprécie pas depuis longtemps il y a eu
entre nos deux peuples malentendus et
moi même par mes faibles moyens
j'essaie d'atténuer cette
incompréhension absurde du capitaine
bangle est à la tête d'un important
service de compréhension de
compréhension oui je me livre à des
études approfondies sur les français
afin de mieux les connaître et par là de
mieux les comprendre
je fais des enquêtes
on
[Musique]
parfait
alors
le 3 décembre
vous avez donné votre démission et vous
êtes venu habiter paris à l'hôtel de la
gare à l'hôtel de seconde catégorie
puis vous avez déménagé et vous êtes
venu le gérer rue des abbesses dans un
le terme employé par mon subalternes
n'est pas exact comment dites-vous des
gens français ah oui j'y suis dans un
réduit exact n'est ce pas à cette époque
vous étiez déjà à bout de ressources
aujourd'hui vous avez même dépasser
cette situation critique puisque vous
n'avez même plus réduit pour coucher
vous êtes bigrement bien renseignements
huit mois etes-vous pour ou contre
l'allemagne
pourquoi hésiter vous
vous êtes encore une victime de la
propagande et de quelle propagande
vous savez bien laquelle le bourrage de
crâne ne peut rien contre la vérité de
la guerre nous gagnerons cette dernière
bataille
je n'en doute pas
alors
songez à votre avenir soyez du bon côté
j'étais seulement à bt au képi je
mettais pas fort et je pouvais tout de
même pas lui dire ce que je pense et
murray fait immédiatement embarqué pour
le cherche midi
qui sait pour plus loin au cas
heureusement je suis pas trop net vous
avez bien dit 1935 1935 le vin pamart
1935 grille car moi je préfère le temps
au ps mais vaut au moins j'ai eu mal au
foie comme été et du travail
oui en effet si vous n'y voyez pas
d'inconvénient commandant mort sa
compagne
alors vous en convenez comment dans
toute son histoire tient debout oui oui
j'ai évité le piège puisqu'il a été en
contact avec le lutetia il est normal
qu'on ait retrouvé son nom mais
peut-être une option nous le demande
ma conviction est faite elle aussi
souvient de nous dire est vrai allemand
d'après le lutetia qu'il faut commencer
à nous mentir c'est à dire elle mettrait
bien que mme harel et rencontré par
hasard ce type de la gestapo il est
parfaitement vraisemblable qui nous ait
dit la vérité sur ce point mais après
elle est sérieusement on sérieusement
mais je me suis exprimé avec la plus
totale franchise et merci le dandy
vraiment très fort deux officiers de
l'hôtel lutetia
oui et il a une connaissance parfaite de
la france et les vins français
alors ça il m'a épaté j'avais d'ailleurs
l'intention de nous épater
vous devez signer mon petit vieux il
fait le coup à tout ce qu'il veut
embaucher pour lutter si on appelle ça
le coût du homard
bien entendu les mèches avec le maître
d'hôtel oui vous ai bien l mais moi
aussi j aime vraiment affronter ça
jamais semblant de croire ces monuments
pourquoi par sport parce que j'ai
toujours aimé blues et le [ __ ] je les
revues au leader
marchons il a même fini par me casser le
morceau il voulait m'envoyer en afrique
du sud pour pour intoxiquer c'était son
expression
mais même proposé d'argent alors là ça
sentait mauvais je vais peut-être aller
un peu trop loin je me suis perdu dans
la nature jour ça allait il suffisait de
pas se faire prendre par les rafles pour
le st omer est la nuit pas question
d'aller dans un motel ils étaient
surveillés moi j'étais recherché par la
gestapo
j'ai eu alors une idée sans me vanter
assez astucieuse tous les soirs après le
couvre-feu je me présentais dans un
commissariat je disais j'ai raté le
dernier métro lyon mais berger sans
histoire
donner c'est là où une nuit g
m
si on m'avait dit qu'un jour je passerai
la nuit au poste
[Musique]
les petits faites vous avez de la veine
de m'avoir rencontré amy je suis désolé
au fond c'est assez pour oui je connais
denis l'histoire ma ronde et toutes
inédites
je vais vous raconter celle du marcheur
et des eskimos aa et les modes de beurre
à celui ou à celle il a déjà entendu moi
je connais parfaitement monsieur le
maréchal un matin c'est venir l'amiral
du service et or ils ne vont pas nous
faire c'est pas le genre de la maison
je vous ai l'habitude et il sait du
polyvalent qui monte au ciel
seulement là les dames aux 15 bouche les
oreilles umut elle est un peu metz
marchez noir fausse car il n'y a pas de
mal à ça quoi
iad auto id mandat son père agite vous
donne en mille
ce que tout en y mode assault pays bas
si vous voulez pas rire et bande de suna
qui est la laine savez je ne fais pas de
marché noir
je n'aurais pas voulu que vous croyez
que à leur résistance
il faut pas vous en faire
moi aussi je suis recherché par ces
messieurs
m
[Musique]
décidément on aura tout vu
même une idylle pourquoi restitue à
paris pourquoi ne passait pas en afrique
du nord
je voudrais une combine j'ai atteint
sous des résistants de nuit ont franchi
les pyrénées avec un passeur
on se retrouve à barcelone
le soir même je prenais le train pour
perpignan la fille ne m'avait pas menti
tout marchait bien et j'arrivais charge
encore barcelone mais lever l'un
barcelone à l'entrée du barrio chino ce
petit bastringue
alors sachez que c'est pas c'est vrai ne
vais pas avoir le coeur à courir les
endroits pittoresques vous deviez pas
beaucoup d'argent qu'elle était aux
moyens d'existence pas les subsides de
la croix rouge
en effet ça doit être plutôt amer et
moitié au ballet de [ __ ]
non décidément je ne voudrais jamais
qu'une brute comment passez-vous vos
journées à barcelone j'étais surtout
préoccupé par mon départ tous les jours
je me rendais à la croix rouge pour
savoir quand je pourrai passer en
afrique
mais dites moi je vous ai déjà dit que
je n'avais ni les moyens ni les loisirs
vélo mario jean devrait lever la tête
non mais cela montre que vous portez
deux points et demi et qui nous distrait
mais très belle et bla oui je crois bien
vous voyez complètement fauché nom ne
dit pas vous l'avez en france il ya un
instant baver avec à paris vous étiez
s'arrosent à n'en avait pas d'histoire
ce sont les bouchons enough l'esprit
jour je vous jure que non pas pour qui
je connais leurs méthodes
un tout leur argent ils donnent une
montre en or pour leur permettre de se
débrouiller en cas de besoin c'était ton
petit viatique a beau mais je vous jure
que non
je n'admets pas que vous parler sur ce
ton je ne suis pas coupable je vous le
répète pas coupable alors explique moi
la provenance de cette montre
assez gênant oui j'ai surpris il te faut
prouver un bouteille on a tout dit tête
mais nos merdes gênant pour une autre
raison vous écoute
c'est une jeune fille qui m'a donné
cette montre non encore mais tu es une
vie remplie de femmes les jeunes filles
que j'ai connu à barcelone a dû
m'intéresse quand je passais en afrique
du nord elle a voulu que je garde un
souvenir d'elle le jour au départ elle
m'a donné cette montre j'ai d'abord
refusé mais elle a insisté pleuré j'ai
fini par céder ouais c'est vrai mais pas
il a quand même plutôt jolis garçons
victoire
tu veux savoir qui prendra pas ce côté
là j'ai pas me plaindre qu'on voit que
je n'ai pas eu envie d'aller faire la
fête au barrio chino avait mieux le
moins cher tu as eu tant payé 1 les
parties avec s'appelle-t-elle mercedes
brute est en danger non car blonde
aurait pleinement pareil vouloir être
plutôt brune vraiment mieux tamer
synthèse sans vouloir elle tu as joué un
sale tour lors de cette montre pour moi
c'est une estampille ce qu'ils apportent
à leur poignet sont classés agents des
jeux elle pas recommencer non tu viens
ici pour me battre
j'ai eu tort d'ailleurs c'est pas morel
des victimes coïncidence voilà tout ça
peut arriver
non pas non plus cigarettes non merci
vous fumez pas si à l'occasion mais ce
n'est pas chez moi une manie
ici les bonnes fortunes je n'ai pas le
temps trop de travail à la base d'ail ou
que vous êtes très bien adapté à votre
unité vaucher voulons défendre jusqu à
l'emportement il y en a même qui était
jusqu à me traiter de sale flic un
garçon bien d'ailleurs mais qui a son
franc-parler brillé à qui je fais
allusion très bon capitaine bonnet de
les deviner dans le civil il mandataire
entraîneur rêve à la ligue ne rend pas
hypocrite mais doit après la guerre des
chefs ont si bien disposés pour vous on
va rentrer en france où chargé de départ
à sion sont hareng pourra être fier je
n'ai plus de pain pardonnez moi quand
même ma vieille ont tous un petit cousin
même temps je vous plains ça doit être
dur d'être ainsi coupé tout jamais une
lettre jamais vous même
n'écrivez jamais à qui voulez-vous que
j'écris et aurait acquis
toi je te tiens le cas menteur un
menteur idiot par dessus le marché
qu'est ce qui vous prend regard de ces
clichés voilà tu croyais écrire à
barcelone sans attirer les soupçons que
nos services étaient composées traitants
et bien non tout elle est en tête des
photographes et je l'espère bien qu il
expliqué oui oui j'ai écrit à la jeune
fille de barcelone tu savais que c'était
interdit par le règlement c'est pour ça
que j'ai nié tout à l'heure tu perdras
un peu ce qu un tonnage j'aurais bien
voulu rater succès me lasse jamais plu
aux femmes qu'un et tu me donner des
leçons
voyons un peu ce que tu peux la raconter
j'espère
que nous nous retrouverons bientôt
le late que cette guerre soit terminée
ça désolé mon team en elle mais il ya là
quelque chose qui ne colle pas et quoi
peut-être mercedes et bien votre
maîtresse
oui mais ces lettres sont dans les
lettres dans la mort tong la c3 banal
l'alma une allusion non c'est pas
possible que ces lettres et été écrite
par un amoureux enfin vous oubliez
également ses mercedes parents très
vieux jeu
les parents espagnols certaines rames si
vous avez découvert une correspondance
amoureuse séducteur mais prudent vous
avez raison on monte on se défie jamais
assez du coup du canapé une lettre qui
draine et hop nous voilà embarqués dans
un mariage idiot on ne m'a pas comme ça
vous êtes mal je ne défends bien non on
est pas si mal que ça la preuve c'est
que vous venez encore de me prendre pour
un imbécile mais c'est toujours une
faute de mésestimer l'adversaire
explications vous n'êtes données stupide
elle tiendrait si les lettres avaient
été expédiés au domicile de la jeune
fille mais elles ont été envoyées poste
restante
qu'avez vous à répondre enfin bon comme
on nomme mercedes et sentimentale alors
comme beaucoup de jeunes filles elle
veut garder mes lettres les caches dans
sa chambre et si ses parents les trouve
moi j'avais morel françois furet très
grave
vous croyez moi commandant de devoir
rédiger un rapport
enfin mais qu'est ce qu'on peut me
reprocher premièrement on avoir
correspondu avec un autre légèrement le
pas dans le rendu compte à leur chef
en arrivant à casablanca pour l'histoire
de lutetia et ça surtout qu'étant du
temps
elle rit au nez me signer une déposition
je signerai mon commandant je pourrais
je savoir perrier avoir de l'avancement
c'est à dire qu'il ne comptait pas on
rapport ressort dans notre dossier il
vous nuire commandant il faut être beau
jouer dans la vie ça a toujours été ma
ligne de conduite ce qui m'arrive je le
mérite j'étais trop bête
ça a été si facile en arrivant ici
d'aller parler à mes chefs et vous savez
ce que c'est mon commandant au début ici
un étape est dépaysé il faudra me faire
parvenir les réponses
quelle réponse le seul le mercenaire je
vous écrivais bien aussi non
oui oui oui mais je laissais détruites
non seulement pour vieux vraiment pas
comment tu vas sortir de là enfin
pourquoi parce que cette destruction
c'est terriblement suspecte on peut tout
supposer le mercedes dans ces lettres
agents des nazis demandait des
renseignements d'armement français je
vous jure que ne s'agit pas noir m'a
convaincu de sa bonne foi et bien d
autres
bon comme on en sait l'être n'ont jamais
existé
quoi mercedes ne m'a jamais répondu non
elle t'a déjà oublié eh ben mon job
copain cocu comme tout le monde se
plaint pas tout mais sympathique
beaucoup plus sympathique que seulement
pourquoi veux-tu cette figure je n'aime
pas quand je dis seulement les allées le
mans battu il ya encore un point qui
pour moi reste obscure lui écrire c'est
une fille elle ne répond pas nous
contentons les avoir mais je ne
comprends plus et quand je lis tes
lettres
si tu tiens à temps là cette mercedes
pourquoi ne proteste du pas pourquoi ne
lui reproche pas de ne pas très beau
monde non dans tes billets doux rien de
tout ça non je veux te dire pourquoi tu
écris la barcelone pour pouvoir
transmettre des renseignements aux
services allemands n'auraient pas tu me
dégoûtes tu ne veux pas moi je te faire
fouiller briller lot n'avait pas le
droit je vais prendre des dents on n'a
qu'une ordure ya livré l'ennemi les
plans du xv en deux
ouais ne tombe pas en syncope de
surprises tu fais marcher a longtemps
que je sais ce que tu vaux quand même à
crach à nos services sont tentés -
couillon qu'ils en ont l'air nous on
peut trafiquer telle lettre tout ce qui
est belle lettre d'amour à l'aplomb le
mercedes les ont plongés dans quelques
balles chimiques mail à encre
sympathique est apparu encore cette
moyenne entre 15 et revient fort bien au
delà des plans de l'avion xdl ce moment
même devant l'évidence tunis c'est pas
possible puisque je te dis que je les ai
vu de mes yeux mais c'est pas possible
alors histoire mais c'est pas possible à
ma base il n'ya pas de x men 2 comme
l'un des plus beaux et non lui x-22 est
encore tenu secret voulais pas me croire
et m'a téléphoné à mes chefs mais elle
est volée lors que tous j'attendais
ben voilà debout joueurs j'ai prêcher le
faux pour savoir le vrai et vous m'avez
quoi ainsi aux services n'ont rien
découvert du tout bon ce n'est pourtant
pas faute d'avoir tripatouillé vos
pauvres l'être au niveau finalement sont
très forts en chimie danse s ils
inventent de nouvelles encres il faut se
tenir sur ses gardes
ça ne pas se laisser avoir par sirois
l'écriture à lisible un peu honte de
vous un traité comme un vulgaire voleur
à la tire cas devait à la fois un
briquet une boîte d'allumettes
j'ai toujours peur de manquer de faire
tache prévaut sur nous porte bien pour
tenir mon pantalon à la fois des
bretelles une ceinture les dumas tout le
match et fait et très chic et des choses
qu'on ne fait pas un camarade de combat
pourtant que nous avons des souvenirs en
commun
aussi j'ai passé la frontière dans les
pyrénées la première année l'occupation
ma font romeu comme vous ah oui ça ne
m'en parlez pas si je vous disais que
pendant la première moitié du trajet un
grand chien noir nous a suivi mon idée
moi et vous faire un aveu j'ai peur des
chiens soudan dans la ville où se
trouvait en danger de mort et un autre à
n'avoir pas perdu mon sang-froid mais un
chien derrière moi vraiment nerveux
surtout la nuit
mais un chien noir et pas moyen de
chasser ce que ça coûte cher
il aurait été capable d'envoyer remarqué
il ya des moments les plus dramatiques
il ya toujours un détail coop 4 ce qui
surgit et dont on se souvient je suis
surtout là mais vous aussi entre détail
farfelues bon on me donnait cherchez
bien
non je vous assure alors un petit effort
le 13 avril
c'était un jeudi
la forme j'ai pris un autocar je suis
descendu un arrêt comme on me l'avait
dit l'arrêt des trois ferme
je décèle il faisait déjà nuit
la route était désert
j'ai attendu au moins 10 minutes
tout tacot derrière moi j'ai entendu un
bruit de cailloux des cailloux qui
roulait suis retourné j'ai vu un paysan
qui sortait de derrière un rocher
cette approche est noir il m'a dit
verdun j'ai répondu mourmelon c'était
les mots de passe et après vous les
suivis
demont pris un sentier qui mentait
un sentier c'était plutôt un chemin de
montagne de l' escalade
sasa mantaise
ce vote est même très dur
le projet fait glisser la figure
de quoi
leach été soufflé
cris même dû m'arrêter
mr comprenez j'avais plus l'habitude
mais si longtemps que je n'avais pas
marché le rôle mais aucune vie d'entre
eux s'y passe
c'était un sentiment peine je plaide y
avait des arbres quelques arbres
il faisait des ombres oui ok maintenant
je m'en souviens c'est rbds amant
rappelé mon enfance il faut vous dire
que j'ai passé une partie de mon enfance
à la campagne alors oui tout à coup j'ai
lu père père comme quand j'étais gosse
si l'ombre mon flanqué la frousse cette
nuit là il y avait donc de la lune non
ça je ne sais pas oui si l'usc avait des
ombres huit années maintenant je me
souviens assez saine une grosse lune
blafarde ligne ou bien non cette nuit là
y'avait pas de lui et rien n'est plus
tôt qu'est ce que c'est un annuaire des
dunes et zon regardes tu écris là c'est
dire le 13 avril 1943 n'avait pas de
lune mais tu pouvais pas le savoir
lorsque le 13 avril 1943
je n'étais pas dans la montagne tu étais
déjà barcelone avait franchi la
frontière la veille
nos papiers qu'on n'avait guère
péquenots mais comme un seigneur dans
une confortable voiture des services
allemands mais je peux même te dire
qu'ils se la procurer cette voiture
le bijou bar ou un bar de perpignan un
ignoble bistrot où les ordures de dans
l'espace jeunes se rafraîchir quand elle
en a envie d'aller faire un petit tour
en afrique du nord pour le service
dessalement non non non c'est pas vrai
j'ai jamais été au bijou barge
j'ai franchi la frontière à former je
vous le jure la neige mais y'avait pas
de l'une des maisons mais y'avait pas de
métaphore c'est vous qui m'avez fort
c'est à dire qu'avec des hommes moi j'ai
pensé bon
la méthode alors s'est débiné dit elle
et pas du nom tu as bien réfléchi wii
donkey morel tu parles trop vite jette
un coup d'oeil sur la date de ce livre
1933 d'un bouquin vieux de dix ans 13
avril 1933 il y avait même pas de lune
le 13 avril 1943 y en avait une
et même une femme la plus hot
c'est un [ __ ] si vous faites avec moi
le diable vous me détestez vous n'avez
qu'une idée me presser et par tous les
moyens
eh bien oui puisque cela vous fait tant
plaisir j'avoue je suis un traître et ce
sont les boss ne m'entend voyez si pour
vous espionner vous êtes content
katchou j ai rien à [ __ ] de vos cachot
qu'obama vrai que j'ai un peu abusé de
vos nerfs il le fallait
non c'est trop des galères ça n'a pas le
droit d'agir ainsi mais comment voulez
vous que je me souvienne s'il y avait
aussi avait pas de lune à longue
distance
moi j'ai beaucoup plus vieux je me
souviens oui eh bien vous que j'avais de
la mémoire vous entendez moi moi j'en ai
jamais eu
j'avais ainsi dans les clo well le
plaisir de vous annoncer
vous avez gagné la partie où il est un
peu ennuyé taquiner mais c'est dans
votre propre intérêt
l'embêtant un soupçon comme on traîne
derrière soi maintenant il est dissipée
oui comprenez vous la faire et j'espère
que vous ne m'en voulez plus bondir que
je suis mal à monter ses larmes
est ce que vous cherchez la cinquième à
lui matt devrait une cinquième a vu
mettre dans la boîte
voilà j'avais camoufler web à fond ainsi
que par le mémoire vous êtes souvenir du
nombre exact d'avis m que contenait
cette boîte est important c'est
allumettes
et ça l'est ou par des talus m
peut-être pas une allumette fait pour ça
lui même
on fatigue et plus à nier vous avez
franchi la frontière en voiture
oui
la fille au commissariat côté de la
blague riz l'oberoi tendu et essien qui
vous a aidé à passer en espagne
c'était plus facile et puis ça vous
amuse les roulés et c'est ça le thème du
sport c'est mon fils je me prendre des
risques en somme on n'avait rien fait
contre votre pays
quel dommage que vous aurez pavillon de
dieu de me dire ça en arrivant tout
aurait pu s'arranger et pas osé mercedes
n'existe pas
c'est une boîte postale encre
sympathique
oui m'avait menacée il m'avait dit que
l'hymne des cendres est alors j'ai fait
semblant de le refourguer des étudiants
hommes sans aucune valeur d'ailleurs
vous verrez qu'elle les a eus jusqu'au
bout moi
qu'est ce que je vais attraper
soixante jours d'arrêt de rigueur non
ouais
12 balles dans la peau mon petit vieux
[Musique]